[MUSIC]
So a few months ago, I was cleaning
out the attic of my childhood home,
when I stumbled across
my eighth grade journal.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In eighth grade I had buck teeth,
size 11 shoes, and
long skinny toothpick legs.
I opened the journal,
and dusted it off, and
found one particularly interesting entry.
It was about what my life
would be like at age 30.
In eighth grade I predicted that by
now I would be married with two kids.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Play professional football for
the Denver Broncos.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And own a self-driving car.
See, when I was young,
I wanted to be an astronaut.
I wanted to be the second Neil
to step foot on the moon.
The first doctor to cure cancer.
But as I got older, voices and doubts
told me I wasn't going to play football.
That being an astronaut,
that's not a reasonable career.
And a cure in cancer?
Good luck.
These voices still plague me today.
Outer critic says, you can't work at
x company, they only hire engineers.
And when I think about raising my hand in
class, I immediately put it down because
I'm worried that what I'm
going to say isn't smart enough.
The voices, the voices in my head,
keep me wishing and
wanting rather than daring and doing.
But I realized I'm not alone.
I conducted a survey and
asked over 50 people this one question.
I wish I had the courage to.
One of my friends said,
I wish I had the courage to bring up
an uncomfortable topic at the GSB.
That I wouldn't be judged for saying it.
Another person said, I wish I had the
courage to leave my high paying job and
start a company.
Another person said I wish I had
the courage to tell my parents I am gay.
What do you wish you
had the courage to do?
See the problem is these voices of doubt,
of fear.
They're crippling our relationships.
They're hindering our potential.
They're telling us, you know what get back
in line, play it safe, follow the heard.
See, the opposite of courage is
not cowardice, it's conformity.
The opposite of courage is not cowardice,
it's conformity.
There is something about finding my
eighth grade journal that brought me back
to my junior year of college.
It was a cold winter night and I was
in an empty college football stadium.
I was cleaning it because
I was earning money.
Because I was a student at BYU.
I swept soggy popcorn and
half eaten burritos with other trash,
I collected it by hand.
I looked up from the trash
at the empty field.
What happened to the dreams I had
as a kid to play college football?
See, voices told me, voices of fear,
of doubt, you know what?
You're a junior now,
you can't play division one football.
Especially not a team that's
ranked seventh in the nation.
One kid said dude,
you're not going to play in the NFL.
So why don't you spend your
time looking for a job?
Couple weeks passed, and
my roommate Josh, he entered my room
where I was laying on my bed resigned
to my current place in life.
NeaI, I signed you up for try outs
he said as he handed me the paper.
You can do it.
I realized that it was easier to not
try out, then to try out and fail.
But I remember the words
of my high school coach.
There's no should of, would of,
could of, there's only, I did.
So despite enormous doubt
given my limited eligibility,
my small stature, my just all this doubt.
I courageously confronted my fear,
and tried out.
And to be honest,
it felt a little bit like this.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's not the outcome that mattered.
But for me, it was that I faced my
fear and did something I wanted to do.
I made a team that winter
only to be cut in spring.
But with new found conviction that
what I was doing mattered to me.
It didn't matter what anybody else said,
it mattered to me.
I attacked 5 AM workouts in
an abandoned field near my house.
I ran sprints,
ran up stairs until I wanted to puke.
I came back that fall,
I tried out again, and I made the team.
I remember standing on the field after
the final game under the lights.
I looked up into the stands.
Where just a season before,
I was cleaning up trash.
I can't believe, I almost didn't try out.
Satisfaction came from
being true to myself.
What matters to you?
What are you committed to?
Do you find yourself wanting and wishing?
Or daring and doing?
Do you find yourself standing in
the stands or playing on the field?
It's been said that if what
we believe is different
than what we do, we will never be happy.
If what we believe is different than
what we do, we will never be happy.
Steve Jobs said it like this,
your time is limited,
so don't waste it living
someone else's life.
Don't let the voice of other's opinion
drown out your own inner voice.
And have the courage to be true
to your heart and intuition.
They somehow already know what
you want to truly become.
Everything else is secondary.
You know what's interesting
about Steve Jobs?
He was cut from his team.
Think about Thomas Edison.
His teacher said,
you're not smart enough to learn.
Walt Disney was fired from the newspaper
for lacking imagination and creativity.
>> [LAUGH]
>> These were people who were
committed to something
greater than their fear.
It's funny to me to think about what would
a world be like if Jobs had given up?
If Edison and Disney had listened?
No phones, no lights, no Lion King.
>> [LAUGH]
>> No Mufasa, hakuna matata, no Goofy,
no Donald Duck.
Hanging in my bedroom wall
next to where my eighth grade
journal now sits is a quote that
I look to when I face fear.
It's kind of long and
you probably heard it before.
But I want you to think about one thing
that you wish you were doing now, but
you're not.
Teddy Roosevelt said this,
it's not the critic who counts.
Not the man who points out where
the strong man stumbled, or
where the doer of deeds
could have done them better.
The credit belongs to the man
who is actually in the arena.
Whose face is marred with dust and
sweat and blood.
Who strives valiantly.
Who errs and comes short again and again.
Who knows the great enthusiasms,
the great devotions.
Who spends himself in a worthy cause, and
who at worst if fails at least
fails while daring greatly.
So that his place shall
never be with those cold and
timid souls who know neither victory or
defeat.
My ask of you,
when voices of doubt and fear
enter your mind, when critics tell you
you can't, go ahead and do it anyways.
Dare to leave the stands and
enter the arena,
because real satisfaction comes
from being true to yourself.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]